as you know we're on this we're just now
embarking on our screening tour for uh
what is a woman we're going to be going
to colleges all across the country
and we're starting we're here we're in
DC right now we're gonna be speaking at
Catholic University we have an update on
that not just speaking but screening the
movie and then we'll do a q a uh we have
an update on Catholic University but
first where we're going next is um the
University of Illinois
and so you have tweeted this yesterday
it says leftists have a battle plan in
place what they call battle plan quote
unquote to try and prevent Matt Walsh's
what is a woman tour at UIUC this
Thursday they're asking volunteers to be
Mischief Makers and plan to assemble a
massive trans pride flag in the audience
so this is what and then we'll put it up
on the screen you can see this is what
they're they're sending around the
activists
um I think they originally yeah they
originally posted this on Reddit
and it says um remind him
talking about me that Earth have no
space for transphobic
what was that remind him that Earth have
no space
remind him that Earth have no space
for transphobic
you don't have to be trans non-binary to
join because you two are a human being
who are very unlikely to get into
trouble
you can participate anonymously so what
are they planning to do they're going to
cause some Mischief during my q a this
is in a couple days
uh-oh I'm walking into some Mischief I'm
getting a little nervous about this you
know there's nothing I hate more than
Mischief so uh what is it okay well now
here's what they're doing they have it
they have it all okay they have it all
drawn out here
I have to say that this drawing is I
mean my nine-year-old daughter literally
draws better pictures than this I should
have hired her they should have asked
her to help uh so battle plan
um the plan is assemble a massive trans
Pride flag in the audience foreign
that's the whole plan
so I guess they want to like by wearing
certain colored shirts they want to make
a trans pride flag and then they and I
guess I'm going to come out and see the
trans pride flag
and burst into tears and run off the
stage I think that's what they're hoping
will happen
we'll see we'll see if it happens
um anyway if you're interested in
participating in this I want to tell you
what their their plan is so stage one uh
there's a sign up form and a and a so
there's you can go to a certain website
you sign up to be a Mischief maker
because that's the thing about Mischief
Makers they always have sign up forms
yes you have to sign up to do mischief
um
uh stage two be a Mischief maker show up
at 7 pm
put on provided shirt
then return the shirt back to us
um stage three return the shirts
and it mentions again return the shirt
so they're very this is the funniest
thing about this to me is that they're
very clear they want the shirts back
they need their shirts back that's the
most important thing that's like stage
three four and five is make sure you
give the damn shirts back
um okay so that's what they're planning
to do and there is an update that was
this is just emailed to me and so I'm
looking at it right now on the spot here
um
and we're being told that
they canceled uh the counter protest is
canceled at Illinois okay so this is all
a big waste of time
apparently this is what they sent out
this is what the activist sent out Dear
Mischief Makers and accomplices
this email is for announcing that that
Thursday's Mischief has been officially
canceled
please do not bring t-shirts on Tuesday
or show up on Thursday night
the reason behind the prompt
cancellation has to do with a serious
logistic issues and B safety of
participants
how can you have logistic issues when
all you're planning to do is sit in the
sit in the audience with with blue and
pink shirts on you have logistic you you
can't figure it out logistically
I am no logistical genius by any means
whatsoever but I could figure out how to
do it I'll help you okay you need my
help I'll we can figure out a way to get
everyone the shirts they need for this
um what are the logistics we collected
more than 60 responses to show up during
the speech even though some responses
are just random responses the number of
participants is much higher than the
t-shirts available Which is less than 10
at the time of writing so they couldn't
get enough t-shirts you wanted to make a
trans pride flag in the audience you
only had 10 shirts how are you going to
make a whole flag with 10 shirts
and then also safety of participants
some responses in the signup form made
us worry about the safety of the
participants we fight and speak up yet
safety and mental well-being always come
first
so it sounds like my safety was actually
being jeopardized so these are these are
people on your side saying things that
make you worried about safety so isn't
that were they planning to hurt
themselves during the speech or where
they plan or were they saying things
that they're planning to hurt me
and you don't want to get in trouble for
that well I don't know but um
anyway so they had their big protests
and they had to cancel it because they
couldn't find enough shirt
you had all this planning and you
couldn't come up with pink and blue
shirts
okay you could just order a pack of them
on Amazon you could order a pack you
could order a pack of on Amazon for 20
bucks you can end up picking blue shirts
for everybody you'd have enough for eye
that I could wear one
oh my God
uh and then what's happening let's see
there's also an update that this is all
just sent to me right now I honestly
have not read it and uh so there's an
update on the Catholic University am I
about to find out right now that our
event was canceled and I'm here for no
reason uh so this email was sent out by
the president of the University
says as the Catholic University of
America we are often asked to defend or
explain our actions in terms of how they
stand up to what it means to be a
Catholic as an example last week I met
with a group of students who asked me to
consider censoring or canceling a
speaker invited by another group of
students whom they believe does not
reflect the values we hold this quarter
identity as a Catholic University uh
here we go
the argument made an impression on me
because it came from a sincere desire
which I shared to create on this campus
an inclusive and welcoming atmosphere
for all students the speaker they
asserted would make them feel unwelcome
and even unsafe while I do not want any
student to feel unwelcome or unsafe I
okay I couldn't agree to the request all
right well done sir uh and then he goes
on explaining why after consideration
he's decided not to cancel the event
and uh
but it's pretty long and he's you know
trying to reason with people and explain
that you know we it's it's we want to
hear other people's points of view he
doesn't I don't think he mentions this
uh through the whole thing but
you know I am Catholic myself and
everything and no he does not say this
I'm Catholic myself everything I say on
the topic of gender and sex all of that
is 100 in keeping with Catholic teaching
100 percent
it's also in keeping with reality and
truth and uh you know so often all these
things line up together
which is the great thing about being
Catholic but anyway
um you know that's also something maybe
maybe it may be worth mentioning and I
know I guess I'm supposed to give
Peter Kilpatrick credit for not
canceling the event which great but but
actually I don't give you credit for
that at all I'm not gonna thank you for
that because uh that's what I that's
expected
okay to cancel a Catholic speaker on a
Catholic campus who's who's talking
about the reality
uh and and of of
biological sex
but that would just be unacceptable and
so he is not doing the unacceptable
thing which is okay good and that will
do it for us today we move over to the
members block I hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow or I'll see you
at Catholic University tonight Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]